avec le profil de soi qui descend et
ensuite on peut
montrer
c'est rare que je ne sais pas les écrits
de napoléon on sait qu'il a
porté pendant dix mois l'année 2010 107
et c'est ça correspond donc à la
bataille de flippant et à la signature
de l'accord de tilsit et donc lorsqu'ils
quittent lorsque l'empereur kit dresde
en 1807 il le confie à son valet de
chambre
qui lui va le confier au gardien du
château de dresde qui rend emblématique
les châteaux des napoléon ces dames
années à tenter d apporter
c'est un chapeau qui est connu dans le
sens et les soldats de porter ce qu'on
appelle en colonne c'est à dire en
vertical et napoléon avait là la
particularité de le porter de parade à
nos épaules c'est à dire ce qu'on
appelle en bataille et ça le rend tout
de suite le distingue en distinctif dans
une dans tous les tableaux les gravures
que vous avez là dans dota les tableaux
au louvre s'était un peu quand il a
utilisé comme son emblème et on pourrait
dire avec des thèmes contemporains sans
logo
[Musique]